here's her on a radio show trying to  explain to the masses what's happening  in russia and tell me is this the woman  who you want one heartbeat away from the  presidency so  ukraine is a country in europe write  that down it exists next to another  country called russia i'm gonna write  this down  gotta write it down russia is a bigger  country russia is a powerful country  when you can read a map you can locate  just about any place anywhere russia  decided to invade a smaller country  called ukraine  [Music]  so  basically that's wrong  lord help us  lord help us one heartbeat away from the  presidency i mean the woman has no  understanding of anything  [Laughter]  she talks and  and conveys information  like a complete  idiot what do you want to know